yeah cuz we're we're we're we're
thinking in terms of like the general
public it's like compared to the general
public but we're our worst own critic
right exactly but you know the man in
the glass and if you've cheated him or
not yeah he's like you [__] and
then I'm in there like that's right you
like that donut I did too that's what
he's saying Joe's in man the glass is
going I
[Laughter]
[Music]
like welcome back to careful boys today
we're talking about what is the one
thing you have made that you're the most
proud of made with your hands or with
your mind I don't [__] know here you
go whatever or in the metaverse what did
you make in the metaverse they don't pay
me enough for this [__] it's a good Duo
what do you mean by made like
metaphorically made keep asking
literally made we're talking about made
men
huh is anything really is anything
really made or is everything in the
process of creation are you talking
about like a hot made yeah there you go
a sexy m is that the kind Min minate
juice change it to that one changes it
right now yeah what's something that
you're proud of that you made Ken that
mental um dang did you make it today
what did I make recently your mind up
yeah oh that's a good one no um careful
he can roast back now oh yeah he gained
the power of selfdefense he's good this
guy I'm trying to think he unlocked it
does no I I guess computer like I built
something I didn't make it but I bought
the parts and put it together the most
proud of thing you made is a computer
that's cool I mean recently but yeah
because one it's like my work and I'm
proud that I made the money to afford to
build these machines to so it's to me
it's like oh I [__] built a beast of
a PC with all this hard work that we put
in the like past few years you know so
it's like kind of like a trophy but also
like you know building a PC does feel
really nice yeah because it's like
usually I buy it for my home to have fun
on but when you earn the money to like
do it for your business it's like it's
like another you know that's like pretty
much it yeah that's actually pretty cool
oh I know mine uh mine is actually me
ooh you're meat I like that no no like
myself like I felt like growing up I've
been uh very observant my
myself no that's what I thought yeah
from from bodybuilding growing up I've
been very observant I've just an
observant kid and I would just see
qualities like I didn't like in my dad
or I did like it my dad or like my
parents or whatever and I'm like I want
to be like that or like I'll face hard
situations and I'm oh man I realized I
didn't like that about myself and I
would try really hard to like fix
certain parts like and I felt like I was
I've been very intentional about that
since I was a kid and I would always
like even like I'm like why the [__]
don't I like cilantro and I was just
like just give me extra cilantro please
and I'm
like and I trying so thisy got a
cilantro I would just always try to like
fix things about myself wow so that's
something I'm like like whoever I am
today cuz even until this day my mom's
like you raised yourself I think and I
was like yeah she can admit that yeah
she'll like she was like you are who you
are because of you that's nothing to do
with me or or dad I was like yeah that's
true I just like raised myself and try
to make kept experimenting yeah I kept
experimenting and tinkering with myself
what would you tell somebody who's who
wants to start that process to start
doing all the things you have very
strong feelings against and just start
pushing yourself into doing those things
I have a lot of strong feelings against
murder we got should they go to Rubios
or
B order extra onions extra cilantro yeah
try it out oh my god dude that's pretty
cool so like building your will pretty
much your willpower yeah yeah yeah
pretty cool it's he's playing Sims by
himself by myself as the only child but
that's dope to edit your traits where
you don't like that you don't like that
takes a lot of self-c control well
knowing that you have the power over
doing it is already a certain level of
self-awareness that like a lot of people
don't have and understand they they can
do I feel like when I think of B I think
of discipline overall like that's one of
the discipline yeah I would I would yeah
I would think of you as like a very
disciplined person you R A discipline
but I I understand it's also like now
the way talk about it it makes sense cuz
it's like oh okay well that's it was
premeditated you were like I'm probably
I need to be very disciplined in how I
approach that
[__] that's pretty deep I thought he was
going to just be like man I made his
prime rib I made it real
good uh well what what I love about what
Nick just said about bart is Bart knows
himself so Nick's like he's disciplined
and Bart's like I'm a [__] cookie
sneaking [__] dude Bart's like I know
myself but discipline about the stuff
that actually matters cuz like it's hard
to be disciplined your whole [__]
life right but it's like there are
aspects that you need to be very
disciplined about and I feel like that's
kind of you but it is true that you
created this guy that we all see as that
disciplined guy but then you know maybe
the complex colors of you that's way
different yeah and I'm not really I'm
not disciplined cuz I like [__] have
all these conversations in my head
trying to relax all the time that's what
I'm saying but you created this guy that
we all see and that's why okay something
I want to share with you guys that you
inspired me to share
is this guy this this poem called The
Man in the glass I think this is exactly
uh your [__] right not Man in the Mirror
by Pete Peter Dale wimb okay he says
when you get what you want in your
struggle for self and the world makes
you King for a Day just go to the mirror
and look at yourself and see what the
man has to say for it isn't your your
father or mother or wife whose judgment
upon you must pass the fellow whose
verdict counts most in your life is the
one stand staring back in the glass wow
he's the fellow to please never mind all
the rest for he's with you clear to the
end and you pass your most difficult
dangerous test if the man in the glass
is your friend wow so if you la yourself
that's I hate myself a little bit you
may fool the whole world down the
pathways of years and get past on the
back as you pass but your final reward
will be heartache and tears if you've
cheated the man in the class wow
that's that sums up life right there
that's like Michael Jackson's song dude
sometimes I have corruption with the man
in the mirror but then he just reminded
me of it cuz Bart Bart's facial
expression changed when you said he's
disciplined and he's like I'm [__]
not but he knows the man in the glass
I'm [__] not yeah right we don't know
that yeah cuz we're we're we're we're
thinking in terms of like the general
public it's like compared to the general
public but we're our worst own critic
right exactly but you know the man in
the glass and if you've cheated him or
not yeah and he's like you mother
[__] and then I'm in there like
that's right you like that donut I did
to that's what he's saying Joe's in man
the glasses going I like
Jack I like to
jack me baby I like
to makes me happy makes me
happy maybe I'll jack off
again who knows only me catch him in
that movie I love myself dude I bet I
could get guess what your answer would
be is this [__] office the best thing
you ever made right cuz I think it's the
best thing you made that's a nice
compliment dude it's sick wow you you
turn that place into this place although
I don't have any other things to really
compare it with I just seen photos of
your other places but who knows if
they're
real they're all very sick my um my
absolute favorite thing I've made uh and
it's it's not like I've made this but I
put a lot of effort into this thing if
you ever come to like a quest event or
like even like Soju or any of our events
the community that surrounds like us is
it's like a quest guys are always good
vibes it's a very good it was such a
cool event bro the So You Think You Can
Dance Like You can tell it was a lot of
love but we're I'm not like making it
but like we I do act for the longest
time since like as for long as I can
remember I've actively always tried to
like make a nice Community around
whatever I'm doing and I think that's
like the hardest thing to do like even
what you did with the JK Christmas sh
was amazing just everything in general
yeah it's just like I think that's Andy
did the office to run the same yeah and
the Halloween party that was really good
good thing we're not being graded on a
curve around here dude we'd be taking
his ass in the hallway on F minus and
[__] but yeah I think that's I think
that's the hardest thing to do is to try
to like make a building Community is
[__] hard I mean you do a great job
even on Instagram yeah
online community you're just good at
building Community it's super hard you
just have to it takes so much time that
you can't shortcut a lot of things but I
think in the end it's like super worth
it and it and then it you know you build
a community and then the community
itself will build back so it's like a
it's like a get the ball rolling kind of
thing but I think if you ever come to
like one of our things and you just meet
people I think everyone who comes to our
stuff will notice that like why is
everybody so nice to me why is everyone
so cool it's like there's like a kind of
almost a hive mind of like be friendly
like say hi to people be cool you know
don't be a creep that's another thing
spreading good I've never felt anybody
with creepy eyes in a quest event so in
kides they all have creepy eyes but they
cover their masks yeah they cover their
eyes with the no no they have the the
straw hat like this they cover the fact
they're licking their lips
constantly looking the chaps M but
building stuff is also cool but yeah
mainly just people it's like Community
build that's insane it's hard nice
building people that's what you do
building grp groups or it's more like
building the comfortability that someone
wants to come
back that's good for real that's a great
marketer what about you Joe um I think I
think I I I I'm very proud of making
dreams come true what the [__] hell yeah
for myself and for people cuz I was
thinking about this I was like what is
is there one thing and I'm like
no I do remember talking to Bart about
this too like very early on in like
YouTube and Just and and then like I
think we made our first million just
dollars and then we were like I was like
man isn't it crazy that we just said
wouldn't it be cool if we had a company
that we can kind of run and just create
content with with our friends and then
just just make a company that's just
different from you know what we thought
was possible and then from that point on
I was like damn this kind of worked what
else would work and then so my I think
there was a pivotal moment in my mind
where it wasn't necessarily the um
Universe just making me lucky but me
actively constructing my world so then
from that point on it was never a
question of like can I construct this
lifestyle or can I create this concept
and make it a reality it was just how do
I do it and I think that was one of the
most liberating like feelings of like oh
now I can just produce music with can
and we came out with like three albums
or like now I can like get involved in
this thing and then open up a shop and I
was like isn't it kind of weird how like
some people will just have one dream and
then be able to accomplish that but I
have one like every month and I'm like
that's true and I'm just like that's
just [__] weird and then and then
it's so normal now to the point where I
forget that it is like usually a big
step for people to to overcome like this
feeling of like can I do it can I not
but once you do it it's like a roller
coaster of like yeah it's not even can I
it's just how and who will help me do
you think that only happened because you
achieved that first oh I made it feeling
because oh yeah cuz I had to prove it to
myself that like oh that would be nice
one day you know like and then I always
hated a lot of the ways companies worked
in my old jobs and I was like and people
would tell you like oh that's not how
companies where you can't you can't work
11 months and then not work the last
month it doesn't work like that or like
I wanted a a a a a way where we just got
the job done not by the hours together
so like we're taught you got to clock in
clock out or or else you're not working
hard but I'm like no there's a project
that needs to be executed and if you
need to be gone for 4 5 days [__] it be
gone and I was like what about a company
that puts family in and friends first
where like we had employees where where
they were like yeah my my grandma's sick
I need to go and I'm like why are you
asking me per for permission here I'm
just going to pay you for the month go
see your grandma and then he was like
yeah I got to see her pass and that was
awesome there's like people that were
like yeah I I got into a car accident
motorcycle accident I work I can't work
for the next two months and we're just
like yeah we'll just pay your your
monthly we know you're good for it like
so it's like for me I'm like dude I had
a kidney stone and you guys gave me a
bonus at a great time and that was
awesome and you got to pay for your
kidney stone yeah really but I I think
it was like it was like being able to
create something where I'm like
society's telling you that's not normal
and it doesn't work that way and I'm
just like well I'll make it work you
know and then that was really that was I
think the moment where I'm like man
anything can just work and if you just
think about the solution and then
there's no real concrete rules in the
world except for like the law but even
that's bendable you know like depending
on what you do and what you can get away
with and who you know and then and and
in this Freedom it just became like the
world is this like the world is your
oyster basically oh [__] is that a new
quote I never heard that one no no I
think it's the world a muscle your
muscle what do you mean like a so it's
like the world is your oyster like but
how so like you eat it clamshell it's
clam shell you guys never heard of that
expression it's like basically like you
can do whatever you want the world is
your oyster that's what people say the
world is like a muscle is what I heard
type your I think the biggest thing I
think the biggest thing is the universe
is your shellfish
oh yeah I heard that one what were you
saying Joe well I I think the biggest
thing is that it came from the World is
Yours SC where is your oyster right
there we know we've heard that [__]
where were you in the cliche go godam
wait what does it actually say though
you're in the position to say you're the
one that's in the what do you what it
says world is your oyster you in the
position trolling Let It Go to take the
does it matter you're going to get
trolled by the troll King I know
all right one big takeaway okay is I
probably felt very helpless before I
realized my accomplishment and realized
that this is something that I was able
to create with my friends yeah and a
team and humans made it happen not
things are happening to me yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then from that the switch
changed and I was like yeah the world is
my oyster I control destinies yeah I
like the scarfish did at any point did
it ever feel to you like oysters were
delicious no that too but like at any
point of your journey of like achieving
all these things were you like once like
dang I feel like I only made this
decision but now all this dope [__] is
happening and it's like it's like out of
your control almost but you kind of just
navigated it that way but you're not
really doing everything you know what I
mean oh I don't yeah I don't think I'm
doing everything it's just Things Are
working out like I don't have a precise
like I'm going to get like 2,000
subscribers tomorrow like it's not
really like that but yeah looking back
and seeing the results of everything and
going like this is [__] crazy or like
having moments where I'm like looking at
the bagio with my buddies were broke ass
[__] and we're looking at it being like
man that' be so cool if we stay there
one day yeah and then I'm like 18 right
fast forward to me being like I don't
know like 24 with Bart and we have a
penthouse there and I'm like holy [__]
and I remember that moment that [__] was
crazy right we had a [__] piano in
our room I know why why what was our
occasion uh we just wanted to do
something nice oh wow get everybody I
know isn't it cool that we're telling
all these stories of what it used to be
like you weren part of the B show one he
was there he got to live through it like
we got one uh one like Penthouse room
and then it was just like every time we
called like yeah we're going to need
like 10 rooms and we just felt so bossed
like book book book book and everyone
just the whole the whole
yeah it was so tight must be nice yeah
yeah man was so cool back in those days
no this is the best days now boy right
now is the best yeah it's getting it's
getting there I'm sure everyone there
was real
thankful Nick did you go no I did yeah
uh something you made I think don't say
[__] kids dude no no you didn't how
you know that was my [__] that was my
whole [__] thing when I was chewing
the sack out of my puppet he it's kind
of a combination of like what what Joe
and and Ryan said too because it's like
I I don't know I feel like every day I
go to work every time I come to a place
of work I feel very [__] lucky and I
feel very blessed that I have like like
I have this place I feel very lucky that
I have the gym in the community around
the gym um my clients that I get to work
with like I feel like I'm blessed all
the time as far as like I I I always had
dreams of like yeah I'm going to be
training people I'm going to be working
with people on a daily basis but I never
would thought it would be what it is
today and and and the people I get to
work with like like like Jeremy the guy
who runs the gym and and the jiujitsu
coaches that we get to work with like
Kenny and Joe and all those guys like
it's crazy to see the community of
students that come through the gym and
how they leave other Jiu-Jitsu jyms and
they're like Yo dude this is the spot
like I don't know what you guys have
here but it's cooking and like we hear
that so much to the point where we're
like [__] really okay I guess I guess we
have something here you know and the
clients that come back and they're like
dude we [__] love this place we I
can't tell you how special this place
was for me and I'm like really like okay
cool all right you know and then even
being here like getting to see how this
place has grown since I've been here and
to the point where you thought I was you
know I thought I was just going to be
like a a semi you know semi guest no you
are yeah you still are yeah you know
what I'm talking about I mean you're
only here four times a month you know
yeah that's
exactly it only took you eight months to
[__] open up yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm a
slow learner I'm sorry cash got so busy
man we
can't no but like to see and then like
the community that that you guys have
that like that I get to be around and
it's I don't know it's it's just [__]
really cool I don't and I know it's not
something I made but it's something that
I get to be a part of so I don't think
it's something like you have a hand in
making it for sure you know what I think
it is it's not something that You' made
literally it's more so of the decisions
that you chose to keep those things in
your life so you made those decisions
for that to
continue cuz yeah really this is just a
space and then we're an organism when we
come together it's not like Bart [__]
puppeteers all of us or you know just
most of us he micromanages he
micromanages me he's like say this he
feeds me lines dude yeah he's like hey
next time can you can you say it exactly
like this hey you want me to disagree
yeah I'll disagree right now just give
me the and then on the other side like
you know yeah it's just cool bro it just
cool be able to work with all these
people that you really love and like you
like you get to grow with you know like
cuz I do love you guys you [__]
losers iing love you guys no for real
though like and I feel like it is
important to say it more often because
you know I'm very thankful for all you
guys are I almost said that for all of
you guys you know and it is cool like
cuz I never thought this would ever be a
thing or any of my life you know so I
just feel like [__] this is crazy every
day every day it's dope too that it led
you to doing other podcast like you do
more than you even want to yeah like
like work with David and Gil bro like
he's on genius brain off Media he's like
oh [__] man these guys all want me no
but but it's it's like I'm very [__]
blessed man I never thought ever in my
life I would be doing any of this [__]
ever ever sick Bro like it would be cool
like I would be like oh yeah it' be cool
but like I never thought it would lead
me to this like place you know oh for
real kind of just got launched into it I
think you you could thank your goofy
reactions cuz I think that's why people
like just you on cast cuz it's just so
fun yeah you're essential as hell I just
feel like I'm having a good time and
Steve's going to make me Rich the crypto
so it's like it's a win-win win win win
win win it's a triple win or else yeah
yeah no he literally said or else dude
if you don't care Rich off this sh I'll
beat your [__] ass oh he's going to
beat your ass yeah he's going to beat my
[__] ass he said I'll learn how I'll
learn I'll become a black belt and I'll
beat his
ass you'll get it a five dude hand
that's what I made so far in my life
that I can say confidently is
millionaires because that's [__]
tight that's gangster what a cool thing
to be able to flex it but the best thing
really is the current crop of people in
my crypto Corner group they know now how
to turn a small amount of money into a
big amount of money which is all I talk
about it's not about risking it all it's
not about selling your [__] house and
buying crypto it's about taking if
you're any good at it right take a small
amount right and then buy Gem projects
that that everyone's missing I'm a value
investor I buy the [__] out of really
undervalued cryptocurrencies that have
massive amounts of potential I focus on
the metrics why people are missing them
and then I buy the [__] [__] out of
them while everyone's [__] off and
you see you always see the same lines in
crypto right it's like a bunch of
[__] going boring and nobody cares
and that's when I'm buying the [__]
[__] out of it and all my people are
buying the [__] absolute [__] out of
it and I don't miss a sing crypto corner
I'm there every week I've been sick I've
been [__] tired I've been all kinds
of [__] I lost a million dollar live I
showed up 5 days straight and just let
everyone know we're going to do it again
there's no way we're not because I do
this every [__] single time and I'm
not just saying that I do it every time
because I know this Market I've not only
told people when the market bottom was
going to be it's all time stamped you
can see it on Discord you can see it on
my patreon channel you can see when the
market was bottom cuz I told you when it
was and then you can see when I said we
have 10 months to make it that was in
January January late January of this
year and then I did a JK video which
just came out of course in December but
we we shot it October 7th I believe and
I talked in those in those videos I said
you have one month to make it and it's
and and in the and in the video I talked
about woji right and koi was 70 [__]
2 7 what something cents 75 cents yeah
was under
woo was uh 18 cents today Woo is
45 Coogi hit
$5.50 wonderful and I was buying the
[__] [__] out of them right the whole
time people making fun of me people
saying like yeah look at what happened
with Luna yeah okay dude I do it every
[__] time guess what I put into Luna
$28,000 when I lost $1.2 million I put
in $28,000 $1.1 million because I cashed
out thank God when Putin started firing
Rockets oh yeah I cashed out 100 G's
should have cashed out way more you live
and you learn but dude I am telling you
it's it's what I'm proudest stuff is
that people know that they don't have to
be subject to our shitty ass Financial
system there is an alternative actually
believe it or not and we still have an
edge on it for however long we have an
edge left right because there's about to
be massive amounts of growth in 2024
Bitcoin ETFs banks are going to be
adding crypto I'm talking about Bitcoin
or ethereum in into their Reserves to
back their own currency to back their
own reserves they're going to be using
Bitcoin and ethereum watch right Watch
What Happens Next was one of my favorite
things to say in crypto corner and my
Corners know like Watch What Happens
Next something I said the whole [__]
time and now they're seeing what happens
next people literally if you could see
my crypto Corner Discord right now you
wouldn't even believe it CU it's like
people posting like I've never seen this
much money before I'm
scared that's so cool people posting
like I put in
$3,000 I made 40 like [__] like that
where you're just like man cuz cuz cuz I
tell you what the the weirdest thing
about doing a show where you're talking
to a webcam and it's just you and people
who are just typing stuff is that you
don't know if anyone's going to do it I
can't make anybody do it I can't just I
can't make you buy I can't make you do
it I don't want to make you do it but
like to see the results that people were
taking it seriously when I said please
don't miss this guys you're you're
you're going to hate yourself later if
you just can hang on for a couple more
months and then remember when Bitcoin
all this Bitcoin fud happened binance
having problems just before when I said
one month to make it just before that
when we had like two three months to
make it I was like guys they're trying
to flush you out please don't fall for
this [__] cuz people are going should I
sell I'm worried maybe I go into the
stable coin for a while and we'll just
see what happens that's how they get you
don't trust them and don't even trust me
trust the cycle that's what I follow I
follow the crypto cycle I think that's
the best me met to follow but it and
it's you know seeing everyone having the
mindset they don't even really need me
anymore honestly that's the best thing
about it they know how to take a small
amount and turn into a big amount now
and that's all I care about that's why I
only charge you five bucks you guys know
I'm not here to farm you I want you to
win for yourself and that's that's my
favorite thing that's favorite thing
I've ever made real quick we one of the
most frequently Asked stuff that we get
to JK um IG is how to join your thing oh
yeah so it's in my Instagram it's um
patreon.com sticky and then you can
you'll find crypto corner right how do
you spell that STI K Ki yeah but that's
and look the people there are the best
it's a JK it's all it's all M it's a JK
Community it's crypto people or people
who are crypto curious in the JK
Community coming over and like dude it's
just the best people they help everybody
helps each other it's all it's so dope
and I'm thankful for the this group I
love you boys and like yeah it's I just
want everyone here to win I I need I
need everyone here to win let's do it
again guys you got to do it again we're
going to do it again Jesus dude you made
me a millionaire twice and took it away
one more
time just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
world